so the moneys are not going to flow to
local journalism um
but the local journalism sustainability
act had so many smart
things in it uh and you have to ask
yourself if you're a member of congress
how can you be against
trying to make local journalism function
in your community
uh because theoretically they'd be
helping
cover you like cover and cover the it's
true
issues you're working on that you care
about um so for the life of me i don't
understand why you only have 50 or 60
members of congress it's bipartisan too
because a lot of the places that have
lost their papers
the fastest are more rural red states
uh you know like like they they see this
problem just as clearly
so i'd love to yeah so this should be
universal and one of the reasons i want
to have this conversation with you is
trying to push this because
i want people to pass the local
journalism sustainability act
so so for the folks that are
are wondering how the heck can you
reverse this tide like what
is in the local journalism
sustainability act that would help
fill this one to three billion dollar
gap um
so uh i
steve is really clever he was uh
worked at the fcc and he did this like
important report documenting what was
coming everything that was coming
actually he's the one who really helps
us get to the one to three billion
dollar number because he's
identified the critical information
areas cost it out away to
a model of thinking about what are the
key things that are missing
and he's also identified a lot of safe
ways
this is more recently now safe ways to
direct money to to news without
fear that the government is going to
control the coverage
yeah which i have to say that concern is
so overblown
because we all watch npr uh you know
it's like
do you really think that there's some
government bureaucrat being like you
know
like stop this andrew yang guy in his
tracks
um you know it's like like the fact that
people are so
concerned that if government touches it
then all of a sudden we'll wind up in
big brother zone
um but it just strikes me as um
paranoid frankly it's like like you you
have models in other countries you're
the bbc that's freaking publicly funded
uh you know it's been going on for
decades and they managed to irritate
politicians of every stripe
uh so there there's no reason to think
that especially if we're remote
like if the federal government sends
money to tucson you're telling me that
some bureaucrats gonna be like
hey folks in tucson like
we've got a school board candidate we
have our eye on like that you know like
that
that's not um anyway
the reason people are paranoid is that
there is like there are
propaganda efforts afloat that are
working that are privately initiated and
we do
have um you know a presence well that's
why we need to do this because you're
seeing
private propaganda fill the gap you know
so so having a non-profit or a public
funding model
um to me makes sense and a lot of the
stuff in
um in so i'm looking over here for some
references because i want to get some of
the facts right
um so the local journalism
sustainability act has so many fun
measures in it
that i thought were genius like you said
very very clever
so number one everyone gets a 250
refundable tax credit
to pay for a subscription to a local
news source so essentially you you sign
up for local news it's free for you
uh number two any small business gets a
five thousand dollar credit to buy local
advertising how fun is that
that's one of steve's most genius ideas
too is that there's
already a lot of government money that
supports advertising
and so we can take we can actually
assemble a lot of money
just by directing like public health
messaging to the places that actually by
the way happen to be the most trusted
sources local news because that's
another thing like we trust the media
except their local media
except local media we all instinctively
trust local media more
um so it's more trustworthy
it is more trustworthy it tends to be
more objective and unifying and that's
why it's
uh it's depolarizing yeah number three
federal advertising budget spent on
local media organizations
uh and tax credits to maintain
journalists and staffers
number four three to one uh matching
donation for any journalism nonprofit so
if you gave to your local
nonprofit paper or whatnot you'd get
matching funds
number five define
public service journalism as a tax
deductible activity
the one i loved the most number six was
an opportunity to reseed
papers from private equity funds that
have gone gobbled up where you could try
and replant it in the community so
here's what happened yes
you have um thousands of family-owned
papers in cities around the country
that got consolidated into a
conglomerate at some point it's called
ganette
or or one of these um and then ganette
fell on hard times
yeah and was then bought by a private
equity fund or a hedge fund it's a
private equity fund
typically um and the private equity fund
then owns a bunch of papers and then
rings them for cash
they look around and say ooh like i have
economies of scale
and then if someone raised their hand is
like i'd like to report on my local
school board and be like well that has
zero economies of scale so no you're out
yeah um but but now they're looking
around for an exit they're looking
around saying what the heck do i do with
my investment because this has not
worked out
even my ringing for cash ruthlessness
has not worked out yes uh and so
if you give them an easy way out and say
why don't just give that paper back
to the community with this 501c3 there
are some local stakeholders
and we'll cash you out not so you make
out like a bandit but that that you
actually make it out alive
um that would be such an enormous win i
thought this was the most genius idea in
the whole thing
oh thank you i wrote it no i didn't um
but
i i agree i really agree i think you're
totally right the
um those the group of us that were
advising stephen working with him on
this
are very concerned about what the risk
is also
for the exit that these um private
equity firms are gonna
pursue that own a significant number of
the
highly trusted brands in our country and
we know that there's a big risk
of a bad outcome because we know as
you alluded to that there are bad actors
who are
uh on on both i mean bad actors
propagandists advocacy
um efforts that are starting new local
news brands and allowing them
to to spew partisan nonsense
um instead of fact-checked stories that
actually bring people together
and so those actors you know exist out
there there is a fear
that is i don't think unwarranted that
the
when the exit happens the papers go into
the wrong hands and so i thought
steve's idea here the replanting idea is
really a genius idea too
um because it says let's incentivize a
different outcome
i'm going to use an example from the
presidential trail that maybe
folks will take to
the main paper that all the presidential
candidates wanted
to get coverage in was the des moines
register
uh because it's the biggest circulation
in iowa and obviously i was the first
state
uh and the rest of it so we just hang
out with them all the time
yeah um or try to yeah and so if they
wrote a good story about you you were
very very pleased and uh like your staff
was very happy
des moines register was bought by one of
these
uh private equity firms uh and like
tacked on to its you know
several hundred newspaper collection
while i was running and so the
journalist i was talking to who was
there was like well we're not sure
what's going to happen now we just got
new ownership and
like it wasn't like a hip hip hooray we
got new ownership it was like
uh oh you know i might lose my job kind
of situation
um so so these are the folks that we've
been relying upon
um for generations
to help vet uh national candidates
who who come through uh and so if you
start doing a number on even massive
pillars of local journalism like the des
moines register like where where do you
where does it end it ends in tears
uh really or it ends in an information
wasteland and like you said propagandist
will fill that
and i'm really worried right now and i
actually started a third
um pr organization um the last month
because uh okay think back to um
2000 the last time we had a contested
presidential election which it looks
possible that we're gonna have again um
and
it came down to florida um the the
apparatus at that time
of the of the newspapers in florida was
so strong and robust like um the miami
herald i think had about 350 person
newsroom at the time
and they just went to town making sure
that um
you know people understood what a
hanging chad was and they were
in the room watching the chads hang or
whatever was actually going on
and and that's that's like really um you
can't underestimate
the difference between what the the rest
of us were just kind of sitting at home
watching cnn
here or or whatever we're watching now
um
twitch here uh when we're
having it explained to us what what is
going on
if the people who are in the national
stage
have that behind them have like all that
350 person newsroom that like
understands the the arcane details of
local politics and local election
administration versus today
the miami herald newsroom is under a
hundred people it's
probably about 50 people i mean that's
that's just like
unreal to think about what's gonna
happen and
it's like we are in a much more insecure
and unstable
um situation in terms of uh challenges
to the integrity of the election
because one of the two candidates for
for president has already decided he
doesn't trust the outcome plus a
pandemic has
made a lot of americans wonder if they
can trust the outcome
adding on to that like the history of
voter suppression
and that that has been kind of opened up
a little bit with by certain court
moves and and so all of that um
is really scary situation like even
right now
because the people that are gonna be
explaining all of this to us have
even less first-hand independent
accounts to
rely on which is why like you said
they'll all be parachuting and then
you know you get there and like who's
there what's the record
and we already saw that happen in the
primaries people
the the you know you you i i love
journalists i'm a journalist and i want
to say you can always believe
journalists but you actually can't
always believe journalists because
sometimes they do parachute and we do do
that
and we don't know what we're talking
about and it's dangerous to say
to scare people about things that you
don't actually need to be scared about
but it's also
um dangerous to to relieve make people
feel
relief when they shouldn't i mean it's
just a bad bad situation so
um so that i was like up yeah
i think journalists have been getting a
bad rap um but i think
a lot of the bad rap they've been
getting does not apply to local
journalists your earlier point
it's like we just sort of trust local
journalists in a different way than we
do
um some of the national media figures
and the national media figures a lot of
the
economic incentives are around feeding
into the polarization narratives
unfortunately
and those incentives do not tend to
exist locally
like if you're a small town paper the
last thing you're gonna do is being like
we're the small town paper that only
half of you are gonna like
it's not really a recipe for success i
mean
like obviously there's exceptions to
every
rule but the truth is that yeah i agree
with you and that's so
so i started a project andrew called
vote beat where we are
deploying local reporters because in the
pandemic we've seen
just hundreds and hundreds of reporters
furloughed from their jobs who have
who are local reporters who have this
deep trusted relationships in their
communities they have
a lot of local knowledge but they're not
working and then there's
um this craziness that we have to cover
so yeah you're matching the resources to
the need nicely done
thank you and and it's one reason why we
have to act fast elizabeth because
these reporters expertise will not be
there forever
uh you know the ability to replant these
papers
will not last forever yes um we have a
window
of time that we have to run through a
window of opportunity
uh and i i applaud you for leading on
this issue
uh certainly before i'd figured it out
um we need to try and get more resources
to the american journalism project we
need to pass
the local journalism sustainability act
if we do that then we'd have a real
chance
um at having people like you
covering important issues in communities
for
decades and generations instead of
seeing it wither away
thank you for listening in i hope you
enjoyed this conversation
if you did please do subscribe to yang
speaks and click on notifications so we
can let you know
every time we have a new episode
you